all right now to wyoming where
congresswoman liz cheney could lose her
seat for criticizing former president
trump the polls show she's badly
trailing her primary challenger harriet
hageman who frequently echoes the
ex-president's lies about the 2020
election the election is tomorrow and it
could have major national implications
for the republican party robert costa is
in jackson wyoming bob good morning
good morning nate polls here show
congresswoman chaney trailing her
challenger by about 30 points but chaney
has long said that this race this fight
is about more than the primary and in
the closing days she has been arguing
that it is also a crossroads for her
party and for the nation
america cannot remain free if we abandon
the truth
the lie that the 2020 presidential
election was stolen is insidious be it
on the trail or as vice chair of the
house committee investigating the
january 6 attack on the capitol
president trump summoned a violent mob
and directed them illegally to march on
the united states capitol congresswoman
liz chaney has sounded an alarm about
the former president's conduct but in
conservative wyoming that could come at
a price we have a committee in congress
right now that they're focusing on
something that happened
18 months ago they're not focusing on
the issues that are important to the
people in wyoming attorney harriet
hageman was once a cheney ally but in
this contest she has embraced trump and
falsely called the 2020 election rigged
winning her a visit to a campaign rally
in may
liz you're fired get out of here
if chaney loses she will be the eighth
out of 10 republicans who voted for
trump's second impeachment following the
capital attack to be leaving congress
four decided to retire three have lost
their primaries just two might be on the
ballot in november
chaney's father dick cheney who
represented wyoming for a decade before
later serving as vice president has
jumped in as well labeling trump a
threat to democracy he tried to steal
the last election using lies and
violence to keep himself in power after
the voters had rejected him
he was a coward a real man wouldn't lie
to his supporters
[Music]
even if she loses cheney will stay on
the scene the january 6 committee
continues its investigation and chaney
has told me that she has not ruled out a
run for higher office including a
possible 2024 presidential bid which
could pit her against trump gail
boy bob one of the few people that said
they haven't ruled it out and they'll
say no i'm not thinking about that right
now i'm concentrating on my own job a
lot of people watching this race it'll
be interesting to see how this turns out
thank you bob costa live from wyoming
this morning